so I got I got a little bit more on this
Jada I haven't been enjoying dunking on
Jada and everyone's actually really
loved us junking our our clip you know
our clip that we put on the C every clip
CH you know our Clips on Duos were like
pretty much deboosted on the YouTube
clip Channel but the Jada stuff since
it's in the algorithm is doing doing
really well all the Jada stuff we do
really well well good we're on Rumble if
you're watching this clip yeah we're on
we're Rumble and this is Stephen A Smith
we say the n-word well let me take him
off the screen go ahead
oh I already said it to to be fair so
does he so does he yeah and I want
everybody to know that before I say what
I'm going to say uh okay you see this
outfit that he's wearing can I point
something out okay you see what he's
wearing I mean which is fine it's just
it's actually a nice don't like his sha
John sweatshirt no no it's actually DOI
gabana sweater right I can see so it's
not it's nice it's nice but that's not
my point he was wearing this same
sweater like uh was Monday Night
Football right they were he was like you
know doing the pre-show thing Monday
Night Football and everybody else has in
nice suits sitting down and he's wearing
this DOI gabana with the chain out
wearing jeans and I'm like bro Stephen I
know you got all the money now and he
does he he's getting paid right but dude
put a suit on like all the other
broadcasters stop dressing like a
rapper [__] that um
flexx on [__] uh I'd come in here and
flex on Michael
strair I wouldn't he'll kill you yeah
like you wearing a suit you house in oh
that'd be great yeah I will remind
everybody I'm a dad I've got two
daughters I'm an uncle I've got nine
nieces I believe the term is Uncle I'm a
little brother I have four older sisters
but how you going say
wife and I'm a a boss I'm a boss [__]
yeah he's a boss [__] and 70% of my
staff are female I'm a mama bear he
starts using all these terms that women
use listen to what he said and honestly
there's some there things about him that
I love like listen to this listen to
this line I'm a
boss and 70% of my staff are female oh
good for you br good for you bro I know
I get it hey hey I'm reading between the
lines I got you bro oh I get it you're a
sexual predator no I he's not
okay I'm kind of surrounded by women
yeah because the power Dynamic and the
uh that would make somebody in my
position one would think a bit hesitant
to say some of the things that I'm about
to say uhoh he's going to go in he's
going in for the
racket I don't give a [__]
somebody need to say this stuff but
we're saying it too Stephen don't worry
about it Kevin Samuels used to say it
yeah beep so I'm GNA say it now here's a
little story I got to tell okay sorry
last
week I felt the need to
address Jada pinket Smith yeah I would
like to remind the world out there I
didn't say a disrespectful word about
her but he about
to and I'm not going to uhhuh I would
never
disrespect somebody's wife I am not
trying to get smacked in the face by the
dude from Independence
Day Jeff Goldblum yes you don't want to
dude he's got a really mean right hook
yeah um what I said was to crystallize
my position is that it was really really
really important that Jada pinket Smith
stopped emasculating her husband in
public the point that I'm making is oh
the exact one I made yesterday I'm With
You Stephen like that's the one thing I
do whatever you want but don't embarrass
me don't make me a [__] like what's
what's his face like the the the NB the
NBA owner they got in trouble for saying
that look I don't care if I don't care
if you're [__] [__] him could you not
take pictures with
them
damn where's your
compassion where's your Dy where's your
respect for marital vows um first off I
was credibly informed that Tupac and
Will Smith would have been friends
yesterday okay Stephen uh it's so much
fun watching Stephen A Smith in what his
40s and 50s just now discovering what
associate PA is yeah that's true why
don't you have feelings why don't you
have empathy it's like that's true Noble
conditions it's like he yeah these
people are broken inside that's why this
is like Stephen A Smith is the kind of
person that would get frustrated and
yell at a [__] kid like stop being
[__] like he can't why are you so
stupid he doesn't know what [__] is
yeah to honor thy
husband and whatever you going I'm not
saying don't feel the way that you feel
or don't do the things that you're doing
privately that's the show that we have
together that's a cash cow it's PR money
for us but you can't put your feelings
aside and oh I'm sorry what I thought I
was talking to skip and it really it
made it's none of our business my point
is it's none of our
business we shouldn't be in your
relationship no I guess what he's
pointing out is like it's only
everybody's business now cuz you
literally told everybody I know what
he's doing it's just funny like he's
doing the same thing we're guilty of
like we shouldn't we shouldn't you know
people shouldn't cover [__] like this we
should cover [__] that matters and we
cover it this matters to me CU I hate
her you shouldn't be on a media circuit
talking about your husband like
that this shouldn't have been red table
talks about
entanglements why he's sitting right in
front of you for the world to witness
God that was so emasculating he was
right there too oh my God when he was
had to sit there quietly while she was
just cocking him in front of
everybody I mean damn and that was and
that was before she had her daughter
write Tupac a love letter yeah yeah I'm
not going to lie the Tupac that she
never had sex with no but there's photos
of her holding flowers on Valentine yes
thank you Marsh yes you saw it too I was
like like oh yeah cuz you always buy TW
you buy 24 roses for someone that's not
touching your penis get the [__] out of
here the guy the guy that wrote hit him
up bought two dozen roses for a [__]
who didn't at least suck his dick that
sounds yeah you're right that's 100%
yeah yeah yeah you're you're
right I'm not gonna lie ladies and
gentlemen I got so worried you're right
the guy that's saying you wonder why
they call you
[__] I'll be wrri about her yeah oh my
God you're right watching Jay to talk
about Will Smith over the years I I I at
one point in time I thought she was
going to go cre says I love that RC is
right next to denes to Souza on the
homepage and you're getting two
completely different shows yeah that's
true and we're the we're the ones that
make him look bad you know he's he's the
Felon yeah it's true for the gut and
start talking about
endow endow or endowments per se as
opposed to entanglements that's what I
thought was going to happen oh you were
going to talk about his dick got it
I mean damn that's how nervous I got for
him Frozen goes I'm just surprised
Stephen A Smith is very passionate about
something that isn't LeBron it's true
that's a good point he fired up about
something that's not involving the NBA
or the NFL yeah I don't give a damn who
you are no
man wants to hear a woman talking like
that children going out there and and
and and and talking and and and talking
about how they wish Tupac was still
alive he picking up all the same points
yes thank you thank you Sten you know
you are you are sometimes a a Monumental
[__] but sometimes you're on point he
is today he is on point I mean damn damn
damn damn he he really is just he just
encapsulates the the spirit of black onk
yeah he does exactly why are you smoking
cigarettes you man come on you won't get
ad dict to them things
uhhuh Tupac
is dead God Rest his soul no maybe and
he'd probably be in hell he killed
people I heard he's in Cuba yeah
hell I assume and hope to God he's in
heaven because of all the contributions
he's made to our society regardless of
his troubles he was phenomenal what are
you for hoping you get to see your puppy
in heaven didn't he like rape somebody
yeah I think he get trouble for rape
yeah I remember correctly wasn't he on
death roow records didn't he also get
shot to death by a guy that he jumped
with 20 people in a casino like hours
prior yeah yeah yeah exactly
yep didn't he regularly talk about
raping other rappers
wives did he beat the [__] out of a
producer at a death row meeting because
he was still working with Dre and he
thought Dre was gay yeah that's right
that's right I remember
that remember when the Tupac account
posted during pride month Yeah couple
years ago and it was like I stand with
the
LGBT verified Tupac account all the
replies were like yeah no no no wrong
way yeah he thought he didn't like Dre
because he thought Dre was gay uh Ice
Cube thought Dre was gay e was probably
gay and he thought Dre was gay hey guys
is Dr Dre gay Dr Dre is gay as hell okay
makes
sense I miss remember when he slapped
t-boss yeah right in her [__] face
t-b he slapar sorry dear sorry yeah uh
it was yeah it was the the
chick yeah yeah yeah you're right you're
right you're right R right in the face
reason definitely G you seen his uh
outfits that he wore in the group before
NWA oh yeah dude of course what a gay
guy like that had big camon energy you
know